So far as each one of these
operating systems is concerned, in their native form,
when they think about physical memory, they think
of physical memory as contiguous. But, unfortunately, the
real physical memory, we're going to call it
machine memory from now on, is in the
control of the hypervisor. Not in the control
of any one operating system. So, the physical
memory of each of these operating systems is itself an
illusion. It's no longer contiguous in terms of the
real machine memory that the hypervisor controls. So for instance,
if you look at the physical memory that windows has, I've broken that down
into 2 regions, R1 and R2. And R1 has let's say a number
of pages 0 through Q, and R2 has a number of pages starting from Q plus 1,
through N. So this is a physical memory. But if you look at this region R1, it's
occupying a space in the machine memory, the
real physical memory, which we call the machine memory,
controlled by the hypervisor over here. R2 is not
contiguous with respect to R1 in the machine memory.
It's been put over here. And come over to this guy, Lennox, and
it has its own physical memory, and we'll call that, region 1 and region 2
again. And it has a total capacity of. M +
1 physical page frames, all of which, zero through
L are contiguous in the machine memory. L+1 through M
are contiguous in machine memory, but, they're not contiguous with respect to
the other region R1. Why would this happen? The hyperwaves is not being
nasty to the operating system. After all. Even if all of the N
plus 1 pages of Windows, and N plus 1 pages
of Linux would be contiguous in the machine memory, they cannot
all start at 0 because the physical
memory, the real physical memory, which we're
calling machine memory, is the only thing that is contiguous. And that has to be
partitioned between these two guys, and therefore,
the starting point for the physical memory, the
illusion of the physical memory, so far
as a particular operating system, cannot be 0.
Also, the memory requirements of operating systems are
dynamic, and bursting. When Windows started out initially
with Q plus 1 pages, and later on
it needed additional memory, then it's going to request the
hypervisor and at that point, it may not
be possible for the hypervisor to give another
region, which is contiguous with the previous region
that Windows already has. So these are the reasons
why the physical memory of an operating system, it still becomes
an illusion, in terms of how it is actually contained in the machine memory.